welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania just revealed what might be one
possible logo or at least a glimpse of
the movie's production design a set
chair that reads ant-man of the wasp
which is really the sound of me spitting
out my coffee when i read bill freaking
murray is joining this movie's cast and
a secret role murray's role which she
already finished filming is as big a
mystery in the mcu as the word quantum
mania itself and i think once we know
what this means we might unlock a lot of
secrets of this movie's plot including
murray's character and the next steps of
the most fascinating villain of this
multiverse kang the conqueror so yeah we
gotta dive head first into
so bill murray revealed his involvement
with quantomania in an interview with
the german newspaper he didn't specify
quantomania explicitly but he said he
just wrapped on a marvel movie and
praised the director of that movie who
it also made bring it on which peyton
reed directed before the ant-man movies
murray didn't go into any further detail
other than to say he's not normally
interested in huge comic book
adaptations and he doesn't need to come
back again but to even speculate on who
murray could be playing it may actually
help to look more closely at this title
logo now i doubt this text will be the
film's official logo a more normal
version has already been released by
marvel in past marvel production set
shares often have their own designs that
aren't connected to the official
marketing of the film but might be a
reference to something the crew
experienced on set and i think the
specificity of this language leads me to
believe that it could be another
fictional in-universe language to the
mcu like wakandan asgardian cree or
squirrel like in black panther the
on-screen titles initially appeared in
the wakandan language letters before
flickering into english but this could
be the language of the quantum realm a
setting that we know will play a huge
role in anime the wasp quantomania not
just for the title being a callback to
scott's line in the previous film it's
quantum entanglement between the quantum
states of posner molecules in your
brains do you guys just put the word
quantum in front of everything or the
fact that the words ant and man are
contained within quantum mania and
ant-man might be trying to rebrand
himself as quantum man but really the
fact that peyton reed admitted to
intentionally inserting a hidden city in
the background of the quantum realm and
ant-man the wasp as hank and janet left
and with jonathan majors as kang the
conqueror confirmed a return in this
film after his debut in the loki season
finale we have suspected that this is
that time traveling villain's home
kingdom chronopolis which in the comics
matches this city's domed structure now
yes there are other subatomic
civilizations in the marvel comics like
microworld subatomica talk but avengers
end game re-established the quantum
realm as less of a subatomic microverse
and more of a separate dimension
accessible only by shrinking between
atoms and in this universe are time
vortexes that the avengers use to carry
out their time heist so with the quantum
realm now as a kind of interdimensional
metro station linking portals leading to
different timelines this city is most
likely chronopolis kang's retirement
kingdom where he collects historical
architecture as trophies from the eras
of time he has conquered now looking at
these 11 letters we can deduce which
letters are which and derive seven
letters of this alphabet q u a n t u
again m
a again and again i and then a again and
you'll notice that each letter contains
at least one circle with other lines
around that circle to connote the
intersections of the shape of that
letter in english for example if you
were to remove the circle from the t
that's a classic lowercase t same for
the u in the n in the a and i this could
suggest whatever culture uses this
language is derived from an
english-speaking one and one that
considers circular patterns sacred so
what would it mean if you consider the
circle to be sacred definitive to your
society and its values oh and while we
are talking so much about circular
imagery here a new series that we're
really excited about here at new
rockstars is the wheel of time on amazon
prime it's coming out on november 19th
and we have partnered with amazon prime
video to talk about the latest trailer
for the series that just premiered today
so the wheel of time is based on a
hugely successful 14 volume series of
novels and this show looks like it's
gonna be a lot of fun for fans of the
books and fans of just big fantasy epics
in general the new trailer is really
cool using the youtube native 360 player
while you watch you can scan right or
left into the dark or the light and see
extra hidden easter eggs the audio also
shifts and there are some hidden audio
cues so you definitely want to watch
this with headphones or good speakers so
let us watch
this looks so cool
i almost don't want to look away from
that
look at all this other stuff over here
oh whoa whoa there's a dark one
whoa look at that face
what is that face
it's a demon face
oh this is scary
it's watching me
whoa whoa there's text mordero
do you think we'll ever go back
past duente
quillbiard
what
no
this is awesome
that was so cool
i gotta re-watch this and pan the other
way to try to pick up on some of the
other details so go watch the trailer
right now at the link in this video's
description so they know that i sent you
and then comment down below with your
favorite moment or any easter eggs you
noticed well it may remind you of the
language mystery at the heart of the
film arrival i love this movie starring
amy adams and hawkeye directed by dune
director danny bill noob they spend most
of the film trying to understand the
circular cuneiform of alien heptapods
who communicate via cryptic circular
symbols not unlike these now spoiler
warning for a rival if you haven't seen
it yet you definitely should but the
deeper meaning of the circular language
is connected with the way these beings
perceive time as a circular concept a
non-linear perception that they link amy
adams character with to help her connect
with future in past versions of her
consciousness to prevent earth's rival
superpowers from destroying each other
and instead collaborating beyond their
linguistic barriers to the benefit of
all mankind i know it's a bit
complicated that's why you should just
watch it but really the oversimplified
takeaway is the circular language was
one used by beings who see time as a
flat circle and in the mcu that is kang
he sees all of time upon the sacred
timeline not as a straight line as we do
but unfolding all at once the time
stream circling around his citadel in an
infinite coil in the windows through
which he observes it all taking the
shape of circular frames he is a
scientist from the 31st century
nathaniel richards and he would have
come from an english-speaking society
who then as a self-declared god beyond
time who sees time as a circle would
cultivate a society in a dynasty with
its own culture and its own written
language obsessed with circles now
another possible design influence could
be the scans from a bubble chamber which
are devices that detect electrically
charged particles in high energy physics
experiments like those conducted at cern
bubble chamber scans showing the decay
of a lambda particle give off a similar
concentric circle appearance but either
way this quantum realm city having a
written language linked either to
non-linear time or to quantum physics or
both tells us that a culture exists in
this city it's more than kang's trophy
room but a place where a society of
people need a way to communicate with
each other and express their identity in
their history and coming back to who
bill murray is playing if you are
looking for quirky hilarious characters
to populate this society bill murray is
a fascinating option as a mayor an elder
or a high priest of this community that
worships at the altar of kang like think
about it over the millennia countless
variants have been displaced by kang's
actions and maybe not all of them were
devoured by eliath which would have been
the hell for those banished souls but
were instead delivered to the heaven of
chronopolis and in that heaven would
worship kang eternally now alternatively
chronopolis could just be populated
solely by kang variants like immortus
pharaoh rama tut nathaniel richards the
countless different names and identities
he's had and this kang dynasty could
have smugly devised their own loopy
language and bill murray could just be
playing one of them but my hope is that
peyton reed and writer jeff loveness
could really just be going meta with
this and suggests that bill murray
himself
the actor and his notorious difficulty
to get a hold of for movie roles is a
result of him being a pruned variant and
kang just collects this comedy legend of
ghostbusters or groundhog day as a
trophy and a court jester let me know
who you think bill murray is playing in
the comments below and you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you